The story of Hachioji Castle
When and how was Hachioji Castle built?
450 years ago, a lord named Hojo Ujiteru ruled Hachioji.
He lived in Takiyama Castle, located on a gently sloping site.
At that time, there were wars in many places,...
...so he built a new castle in a better location.
The new castle was built where the god Hachioji Gongen lives.
It was named Hachioji Castle after the god.
It was located in the steep mountains and was easy to defend.
Moreover, Mt. Takao was close to Hachioji Castle.
Mt. Takao also helped protect the castle.
Izuna Daigongen, the god of battle at Yakuoin Temple on Mt. Takao, was worshipped.
Therefore, he respected the mountain and the temple very much.